i asked my friend because my friend's
dating right now and i'm like how weird
is it
and he was like it's first of all it's
super weird
people have in their profiles like i
have antibodies
i just got tested all this stuff wow and
and then he was like i met up with this
girl and she wore her mask the whole
time
and so i wasn't really sure if she was
like into it or not and then at the very
end of the date she took her mask off
i'm assuming because she wanted a kiss
but that he read that as like okay i
guess she's into she's into this
it's just funny that that's an indicator
now yeah
that something's going well is dude she
took her mask off bro
she trusts me
[Laughter]
yeah dude you guys bone first date yeah
dude mascot
mask off dude mask off the whole time
too
i can't wait till they start making like
um lingerie masks so when you go to hook
up she's like hold on then she goes into
the
she goes into the bathroom and she comes
out and it's got like lace and [__] on
it and you're like oh
yeah you're like oh my god breathe into
my mouth
and it's like it's like lace over her
lips so you can like kind of see it
yeah she's like do you like it when i
breathe on you you're like oh that's
[__] you're such a [__]
dirty girl you're can we do it can we do
a missionary please
please i want you to breathe directly
into my mouth let me just do a
missionary then she blasts the particles
on him
oh dude dude how how was it man dude
she sneezed on me what no
you gotta sneeze on the first date
coughing directly into the mouth
less than you going raw yeah that's
oh my god so we're like
or whatever you know we're like we're
like rubbing noses we're kind of like
trading mucus it's like really sexy and
then
i pull his mask down and he opens he
says
do it and i pull mine down and i go
[Applause]
it was the hottest thing i've ever done
in my life it was so hot i could see the
little phlegm
little flam bubbles someone on his face
too
there is someone single and lonely right
now listening to this being like god
what i would give
for someone to cough in my mouth yeah
yeah you know what gleeking is
oh yeah you know gleeking isn't it
dustin you're squirting yeah i gleeked
i'm gonna gleak i'm gonna glee
sounding like that
just spitting up like that water like
i'm gonna click i'm gonna click i'm
gonna click
spitting up like a water gun from the
dentist just [__]
one tiny little stream
like when you drop a can of soda
and you're like dude you're like you're
like rubbing her nose like it's her
her thing and you're like she's like oh
my god i'm gonna click i'm gonna leak
and you're just like
mashing on the tip of her nose just like
holding it up so her lip can be held
back
so just it goes crazy
you know that [__] they do in a
squirting video or they're like they're
like rubbing their hand over the [__]
stream
[Laughter]
uh
she got a dental bib on to claim to
catch all the [__] spit
[Laughter]
i'm like i'm gonna click
ladies ladies and gentlemen you're going
to learn how to gleek right now because
that's the new that's the new
freak [__] in 2021 trust me that's the
new cake sitting
if you want if you want to make bands on
only fans
start gleeking right now get ahead of
curve
[Laughter]
holy [__] dude she was such a freak dude
she gleeked
all over me dude it was easy you know
that's just p
right wait girls be out of their mouth
it's just pee dude so like does it like
come up from the [__] like i don't get
it my god
you